when you land in each country the
producer of the event gives you a
booklet of
challenges you cannot use any
electronics which is so
scary because we're used to googling
everything
[Music]
zoe thank you so much for being on my
show 20 minutes later i cannot believe i
have you on this show this is amazing
thank you for having me that's great so
um disclaimer your son is one of my
brands
and huge inspiration for me all the way
back from high school we met
on the playa at burning man i believe it
was 2014 when he graciously invited
my father and i joined your wonderful
camp which has evolved so beautifully
over the years
we've joined you three times already and
had three
life-changing experiences at burning man
but
while you're a burner and you're all
competing in the world in the global
scavenger hunt actually competing you're
winning
the global scavenger hunt more competing
you're actually a pretty incredible
litigator
and fighting for some really important
causes
zoe who are you once and for all clear
this up for me who are you
um i think i'm a person like most people
that are um
working hard in their profession is i'm
a lot of things you know i'm a mom i'm
definitely a burner
i definitely am addicted to adventure
travel and um
i had the great fortune of choosing a
career that i love
and that has always brought me great joy
and
frustrations and successes and failures
um but i think if you start off on a
track
that you know you love um you're never
going to be bored or disappointed
wonderful you know i mean the the the
jewish
mom tradition that we know is yeah
you'll be a doctor or
regardless if it or not but you're a
lawyer that you love you're doing
you're litigating why love it so much
what is it about it excites you
when i was a little girl i knew that i
had
um an inherent talent that i was not
afraid of speaking in public and most
people are terrified of speaking in
public so it's sort of like a
number in the world yes it's a
superpower if you're not afraid of it
and i
realized i liked speaking in public and
i wasn't afraid of it and there was only
a few professions that pay you to speak
in public politician lawyer
and so very young i realized i wanted to
litigate
because that was a way to get paid to do
what i liked and what i
had an inherent talent for one well you
could have also gone you know to
la and hollywood and go on broadway but
he chose to be in the courtroom
but the courtroom is theater in its own
way if you are not entertaining and
persuading
and keeping the jurors attention you're
not winning ah
i love it okay so so litigator lawyer
and and what type of lawyer are you
because you get to deal with
some really crazy cases it's not just
this you know these
ordinary cases that we hear about on tv
i have been lucky in that i never had to
do
sort of entry level legal work of car
accidents and slip and falls i got into
a practice
early on that did big cases and then i
formed my own firm
and i've always had my choice of cases
so i got
to choose the people i represented i've
always represented people
injured by the negligent or gross
negligent conduct of
corporations and other people and i have
had great the honor of speaking
for people whose lives have been
destroyed
by the negligence of others and that is
a true
honor you know that that's insane
because uh
it's not just about somebody's life
being druid and then going for them and
speaking out about it but you're
actually
cleaning some huge corporations hundreds
of billions of dollars or 100 millions
of dollars
who have in you know in comparison to
the resources that the individual has
it's uncomfortable and here you come say
we're the underdogs
i'm going to pretend you are going to be
better than than the
dozen lawyers that they're putting up
but how fun is that is to choose a
profession where the people you're
against are the best money can buy
i go against the most powerful and
well-funded corporations and they can
afford the best lawyers which means
you're
always going against people who make you
up your game and be the top of your game
yeah i'm not sure you can disclose this
but is there like one case of
one example of a case that has been
public disclosed that you can
just mention what type of just to give a
context of what types of cases you're
you're tackling
yeah so for a long time i represented
women who had developed breast cancer
from taking a defective drug
a hormone therapy drug and menopause and
there were women who should never have
had breast cancer their family had
should never have gone through that
experience some of them had died
from the breast cancer and it was um
really rewarding they were older women
who had been very trusting of the drug
industry really trusting
that the pharmaceuticals they were
taking were really just going to be
beneficial and not hurt them
and then they got this terrible
diagnosis and went through years of
treatment and fear and so representing
them and getting justice for them and
their family was incredible
and it was against both wyeth and pfizer
two of the largest
companies in the world unbelievable
unbelievable so so paint me a picture
as you're standing there in the
courtroom and you have a jour and you
have a jury
and and you're talking about you know
these are emotional
subjects people's lives are being ruined
how do you even
go about approaching a case like this
when you're saying like wow i have to
deal with
with pfizer and wyatt i think you have
to come from a place of gratitude
that your client has has
gifted you this opportunity to speak for
them
my clients either are dead or sick they
can't understand the concepts of a
courtroom and they
need someone to advocate for them so
being a litigator is truly an
honor of being an advocate you get to
tell their story you get to
show the jury what they went through the
decisions that were made at the
corporate level that
were decisions that ended up really
hurting this family and this person
and once you come from that part then
you speak with authentic passion
because i truly believe in the
um
in the veracity of my client's case i
believe
in what they're trying to do and then i
speak from my heart
and once you are passionately trying to
get that message across the juries will
listen
zoe that's beautiful and i have to say
that while you're explaining i i
i i don't know that of you in court
because i know that
at burning man and you know going to
going and eating dinner together
outside of bernie but you know the
side that i also see is that you're
bringing this heart and passion to your
personal life i mean i'm meeting these
people
that are joining our our camp at burning
man who
lives you're literally transformed and
they have so credit for the
you've given them a minute and i know
they're too humble to come and say
yeah i did that but but it but it's true
and i speak also personally and
and there's like zoe zoe did this for me
burning my butt
my whole life and i think just it's
remarkable and it just shines and you've
been
an inspiration for me over these past
six years that i've had
that have had the privilege of knowing
you but you're also so adventurous out
of the courtroom
talk to me a little bit about this this
burner what is it about burning man that
attracts too much
i think if you haven't been to burning
man it's hard to put it into words but
there is a
impossible yeah there is a core to
burning man which is a belief that
together we can be better
that if we have each other's back if we
go into the desert with no water and
electricity and you can't buy or sell
anything you have to rely on each other
to survive and to have fun and it's hard
fun you know you're hot
you don't have air conditioning hard fun
you know it's hard fun
but if you can do that if you can really
embrace the
sense of community and the together we
are better
then burning man is a transformational
experience
as you feel the zen of that community
definitely definitely and
so just to paint a picture the burning
man project is
uh seven or eight days where we go into
the desert the playa black rock city
about three hours into the nevada desert
and we form a community of about
70 or or 80 000 individuals that are
becoming a
family as sort of like in a uto in my
mindset
and you know one of the things that i
also spoke about this with my father
extensively
the first time we came uh you you ride
your bike down down the street that that
you create
and there's not a single piece of trash
on the whole
and you just think you feel to yourself
wow there's so much junk that everybody
is bringing in and
and you know the the fact that you have
to take everything out with you and
because of the social responsibility we
community we keep it clean and we keep
the same values
i think that just incredible and and the
world can learn so much from this
project
i agree and you know what we learn is
that if we
have to rely on each other we all have
to uphold that societal bond we have to
take care of ourselves we have to take
care of our own trash we can't leave
other people
to pick up our leftovers you know we
have to work together
and that is the sense that's the essence
of burning man
definitely definitely okay and and so
we're going to leave time and talk about
the athena project that you're that you
just started about before that uh
you are competing in one of the world's
craziest
adventures the the global scavenger hunt
which is
the number one on my bucket list to do
and you're not you're not only competing
you're winning it almost every time that
you participate tell me about this
global scavenger hunt
everything and you go around the world
and do these crazy experiences
it's a wonderful non-profit that raises
money for charity
and it's put on by an inspired couple
who really believe
that the way for people to appreciate
being global citizens
is to see the world in a new way and so
it's a blind date with the world you
don't know where you're going
you don't know how long you're going to
spend there you don't know what you're
going to have to do when you get there
and you basically blindly take this date
with the world you show up in
some place on the west coast and for the
next 23 days you're going to go west
around the world
circumnavigate the world you're going to
stop in
11 12 13 countries each time you land
i know you don't know which ones
you get one small suitcase so you have
to sort of pack layers because you don't
know if you're going cold or hot
and when you land in each country the
producer of the event
gives you a booklet of challenges
scavengers puzzles things you have to
discover
decipher clues you have to use you
cannot use
any electronics which is so scary
because we're used to googling
everything
you cannot use any electronics you
cannot use any electronic maps
you have to walk out of the hotel and
just stop people and start interacting
in whatever country you are
using charades because you don't speak
the language and have
locals from that country help you
decipher these scavengers and point you
in the right direction and get you to
the places you need to go to make the
points
and in each country the person who does
the most makes the most points
and wins that leg and then if you win
enough legs then you become first second
or third in the competition
but it's all wonderful of course of
course no but so effectively it's like
the amazing race without cameras
more authentic and for a good cause for
charity
and it's designed to try and make you
look at things from a different
perspective
so for one example we were in cairo and
obviously if you're in cairo you want to
go to the sphinx
but we had to first go to the grand souk
and buy traditional african headgear
then we had to go to a camel
stable and rent camels we had to put on
the african headgear
get on the camels ride over the dunes
and we
approach the sphinx from the dunes
on camels in african headgear
so you see that experience of
approaching the sphynxis from a
different
from a different way a more authentic
interesting way and that's what he wants
you to do get out of your
tourist mode of where we're going to eat
next what tourist attraction we're going
to go take pictures at
and do something different when we went
to china you had to run a mile on the
great wall of china like you didn't just
get
so off deeper picture you had to do
something
when we went to tiananmen square you had
to approach a family and get them to
agree
to fly a kite with one of their kids and
take a picture of you and the kid
flying a kite in tiananmen square which
means you had to interact with people
and
talk to them and explain what you were
doing and ask questions and
feel like you were really appreciating
the country in a different way
so it sounds so incredible okay so at
the athena
the the female joint project uh to
empower women litigators
uh the the video is
so amazing and it's so inspiring but
tell me a little bit about what how did
this come about especially in times of
kobe 19
well pandemic we're all shut in and we
just had this brainstorm
of we there are very few women run law
firms
still i know that's incredible but it
still is true
and six very powerful women who all run
their own law firms who are
really well respected in the in the
field
decided why don't we start pooling uh
our reputation and everything that we
have
put together over the decades and help
other
women litigators so women who leave a
law firm
to start their own shop and they can't
get a credit line
could we provide funding women who think
uh when they show up at mediation they
don't have the reputation to really get
full value for their cases can we put
our name behind them
can we help those people brainstorm can
we help those people
redo their trial strategies and one of
the things we found is when
uh men run firms came to us for help
getting their trials together redoing
their case strategies
one of the requirements was you had to
have a woman on your trial team or we
wouldn't help
so you know just trying to push more
firms to think
always can we have a diverse trial team
can we make sure there's at least one
woman on every trial team
to put more women in the courtroom i
love it i love it so
tangibly how does this work because the
six of you you you're running your own
firms you're extremely busy with your
own cases
so are you sort of like a board you have
applicants come in and you follow
relationships and you back them both
with
perhaps funding but mainly reputation is
that how it works
yes or we can work with them if they're
if they've got a case that they feel is
a little bit too big for them we can
come in and help them try the case we
can work with them
um we can share the funding on the case
we can share the fee on the case
we the purpose is to really give women
options that
is not really available right now of
having support
money reputation experience
um and to just kind of do plus honestly
we just love working together and it's a
great opportunity for us to work
cooperatively
me and these other five women that i
love and who are so
talented i learn every conversation we
have i learned so much
about how they look at a case or how
they work on the case or
different ideas of how to um really make
something more persuasive
so it's just been great fun but i think
we also have an opportunity to do some
real good
i love it you know so we just have a few
minutes left but i'd love to
i'd love to pick your brain as someone
you're you're dedicating your life to
community
people and to thinking of uh thinking of
who has wronged who and how can we
correct this this wrong doing
and i'd like to go up maybe you know 30
000 feet in the air
and sort of look at our society and
hear a little bit about what you think
what what we do
as sit as global citizens to improve our
society and to boost the number of of
these things that are happening very
cliche but i want
but i really i am interested in your
opinion about this
i think the most important thing is that
we have to accept that we are global
citizens
we are not americans we are not texans
we are not californians we are global
citizens
in this world everybody is connected and
maybe it's because i'm an immigrant
but i think it's really special when you
start to see your place in the world as
not just
a person but a global community and that
requires us putting down
some of our nationalism and populism and
really working together to make the
planet a better place from global
warming to climate change to trade deals
we have got to work together the
inequality the
income inequality is is startling
we have got to make the whole world a
more equitable place
both in terms of the planet and just
what we do every day and that
starts with us thinking of ourselves
as a part of a very big picture which is
this whole planet
oh definitely but but you know so it
sounds like so so this is sort of a
bottom upper saying
we need to rethink our values and to
understand that we are
we are global citizens but at the end a
lot of is also
top down where you know we're most of us
are following along
the different politicians up there or
the different leads
that that are dictating sort of how we
should have and how we should think
how tangibly can we be can we
can we tackle this and how we expect you
know
300 300 million people to think for
ourselves and not just take for granted
what what the leaders are necessarily
saying
i think we have to come from a place of
much more kindness and loving
uh appreciation than we do right now the
divisiveness has got to stop it's got to
be it's we've got to stop being
different tribes
i mean this country is tribal and really
we're
all global and yeah we've got to get
back there we've got to stop the
divisiveness we've got to appreciate
each other love each other be kind to
each other
and particularly now take care of each
other
keep people safe do the right thing so
that everybody even the vulnerable and
especially the old
are protected and we've got to
start rethinking that and and put down
these tribalisms in this divisiveness
a hundred percent no you know i i took a
fasting course at stanford
uh this this year it called the spirit
of democracy
with the world expert larry diamond and
the thing he's talking about is
deterioration the deterioration of
democracy
not just in the us but around the world
and part of it is that we we so we
forget to to look up and to to consider
what's actually happening around
and get out of the small bubble that
that we're being fitted in
uh sometimes wrongfully and i think
that's i i definitely agree
kindness empathy on i think this this
scavenger hunt this sort of ability to
go and meet these different cultures
flying a kite in tiananmen square
instead of going and taking a picture as
a tourist that's
that's definitely i think at the right
path zoe
before we go i ask you the hardest
question and i'm putting you a little
bit on this
here but i'd love for you to tell me
three words that best describe you
um i would probably say passionate
because i feel very strongly about my
uh my career and what i do for a living
i would say uh generous because i think
it's very important that people who have
had gifts and had opportunities be
generous to others
don't pull the ladder up behind you but
help other people up that ladder
i love that matter and i would say
spirited
because i'm a force to be reckoned with
when i put my mind to something
a hundred percent um i i can definitely
test i did that
zoe thank you so much for the time thank
you for the inspiration with everything
that you're doing
it's really wonderful and please send
send my regards to your wonderful
wonderful son
thank you and good luck to you love